hello and welcome to this video am shed
sharaf who is that no name okay yeah the
Queens gambit evergreen opening yeah I
have no good reply to the rosin III is
more than yeah backup move let's say I
have to look I mean there's nothing
brilliant against it anyway it's one of
the most popular openings at the moment
on top level chest the rug goes in but I
should at least check if I can find
something that I like again certain this
is just transporting to a mainline nimes
l which is okay of course but not
exactly what you what you want yeah just
shoot for normal development okay my
bishop is hanging there sometimes also
couldn't be three in these positions
and I don't know mmm interesting so he
has taken them as black usually does so
and let's go for the hanging pawns see
what is doing here quite often black it
goes for e 5 here Ruby 85 it's not so
easy here okay maybe you create and
intending to take f3 and then e 5 this
is the possibility for sure
ok so it seems he is going for that I'd
like to play the bishop to g3
yeah the bishop is nicely placed on g3
sometimes black plays Knight h5 in this
kind of situation to preempt Bishop g3
but it looks a bit strange in this
particular position the night now he
still plays it I'm not sure about i mean
i just also didn't say it's bad i just
said it is strange
yeah like five maybe and that's the last
interesting ride a for Bishop g3 that's
might be tricky for him oh that one hmm
I didn't expect this move
hmm interesting interesting yaquina for
becomes an interesting option now for
him
hmm what to do him i have c 5 is
interesting 25 is really annoying
you
huh I don't know what to do against it
rookie five looks very weird I can go
Bishop g3 bag but it's it's like
absolutely nothing that's very very lame
but I didn't see anything good against
krina form
now he's ok now just rude ed ade and
looking at my pawns that's at least
equal for black maybe maybe better I
don't know
ok
yeah this is this is this is annoying
here I can do this I can take deform
oops yeah of Quincy form but he could
have taken deform that would have been
better I think okay baby yeah maybe you
can do this check it's not completely
completely insane or anything
this to have have some play and supports
with possible f4 and so on at least this
Bishop looks threatening on v3 wants to
go to c5 I guess this will get Queen
trade winds material back time morning
okay and I go back
I don't know is that good I've got 96
okay I know that he can take that so
that's a bad move I'm really playing
this badly this game check check check
check thank you I'm slightly ahead on
time now okay whatever that's worth okay
the point is pretty good but I cannot
attack his pawns there this is the thing
I don't get to spawns black for Fitz one
time I didn't even look okay damn hey
it's a draw it's a draw I thought maybe
with the bishop in the airport that I
cannot win cannot win here it's just a
draw goes over to the airport yeah cool
i should have lost this game plated
related badly yeah this is for some kind
of critical phase of the game and I
didn't really see that move coming that
df6 and this is really an issue Queen f4
it's very annoying him
pin the engine wants to play Bishop to
d3 is just very poor I mean it's the
kind of move that that basically says
okay you are you are good now right the
engine wants to play this but I still
don't see a move against this at g 3t
three looks like blood but maybe you
have to his lights also have their
problems nay ok computer it's a is
giving this that's obviously realize if
it works huh yeah that's not very human
but c5 is to move that at least keep the
position yeah in some way that you can
maybe hope for more than equality and
here this is just just not yeah not nice
at all t5 is a move you don't want to
play and here yeah this is not totally
clear this position I should have taken
a seven here it's not totally clear but
the way it went I had a clear
disadvantage without any particular idea
yeah yes I already had to do yeah he
screwed that end came up step by step
from from from a flat win till until it
was said it was drawn yeah here 94s for
example I'm much stronger well and have
em two pawns down for nothing yeah I was
lucky to win it in time at the end okay
well thanks for watching